tonight's a very special occasion
for two people
um
myself
and someone that I've known for
best part of 40 years
since a Tony
I'm going to bore you a little bit with
a bit of History if you like and I'm
sorry for that but
in
1960 it was either 63 or 65 I can't
remember I was posted to RAF Whitton
near Huntington
and I lived in Whitney in Oxfordshire
and I needed somewhere to practice my
Aikido and I in those days I'd noticed
thing as Google and whatever we got
today you went to the local library and
you found out you know what what sports
places there were and there was an Ikea
Club at the Howard Mallet Club in
Cambridge
and I thought I'll go along there and I
went along there one night and walked
into the club and said can I join the
class and they said yes I said is since
this since this Sergeant here and I said
no he's um I think it was you either New
Zealand or
Australia they was with Saito sensei so
uh
the fellow called Russell Everhart was
the senior Amanda senior per student at
the club and he said well what grade are
you and I said um I'm a first down
and I think he was first Q at the time
and he said well you've got to teach
the etiquette being you know uh to
senior person teaches they didn't know
me from Adam I didn't know them from
Adam but I've got to teach so I I saw on
the the wall in the in the dojo in the
Howard Mallet all these weapons you know
loads of Bakken and loads of Joe and I
thought oh perhaps they do some weapons
so I said um
do you know the uh
the 20 Joseph Brewery
yeah
also do you know the 13 count Carter
yes
um do you know the third T1 count cutter
I saw oh heck you know
um what am I going to do so I said do
you know the 25 count cutter
no so so we we uh we spent the evening
doing the 25 cutter which um uh when it
was mentioned to um Sensei Sergeant he
said that's not part of the awarma
school no drop it it doesn't exist so we
never saw it again but um uh I
thoroughly enjoyed myself and I reprised
it uh
um late last year with the Cambridge
club and again tonight
um
but Tony and I have been
corresponding and keeping
Aikido alive for the last 40 odd years
and
it is my greatest pleasure tonight
Sensei Sergeant
to present you with a couple of
certificates so if you'd like to come
forward
you know this is fine yeah
the first
the first certificate
says
the Aikido Alliance UK which is uh the
organization to which we currently
belong hereby Awards Tony Sargent the
rank of seventh Stan
this is difficult is signed by Bill
Harris who's my uh Sensei and Kai
shinkai he's the chief instructor and
he's signing it on behalf of the Aikido
Alliance the fact that um it's been
given to me today to present this is
an honor which
I I never never expected
um to be given
um sorry it's Wednesday please accept
this
all right
um but there's there's another one to
come as well so I used to give me a
minute
this um this second certificate
says Tony Sergeant has been trained in
the awama Ikea for many years and in
recognition of his outstanding
performance in both technique and
outstanding contribution to the
development of Aikido
he is awarded the title shiham
this certificate again signed by Bill
Harris
Chief instructor of the kai shinkai and
on behalf of the Aikido Alliance UK
I have to say that um
Bill Harris did pass on to me which I
forwarded on to Tony
his how honorable uh how much of an
honor it was for him to
um to have his name on your certificate
once again
Tony I'm
I'm
not worthy but there you go
okay thank you
but I think Tony has got something to
say
God
thank you
I'll just write some things they are
normally the person receiving that's you
know the award doesn't speak
we're old so we get we break the rules
uh I wanted to thank you all for being
part of me receiving this because uh I
started in Cambridge
50 years ago in September
you know even I find that quite stunning
to think God 50 years if I had somebody
tell me that I think does anybody live
that longer alone train that long
so so I thank you and um
I started at the age of 23
just in the center of Cambridge
and
really we've been mad about it ever
since haven't we yeah
it's very strange
um
when I was young I used to go on lots of
seminars and they're all Japanese
senseis but all the ones that I saw were
six stands I don't know why they said to
get the six down and that was like the
seat next to God so my goal was to get
the sixth down so I don't know where
I've got these really but um
so that's what I achieved for now that
was a lot when you think that you're
just a colored Bell you know you're just
a colored bat to think you know I want
to be sick because I want you to be like
those that I saw those people who were
outstanding
I don't think we actually live
in there we're in their Shadows really
because to me they're still
if I was sent down they must be 11th you
know but but people say that because we
don't see how we advise
so what I want to really give you is uh
advice
and that is the old future like you know
always think you're a student
if you do get Grandeur and you start
thinking that you're something special
just remember you are a student
you keep that